doesn't love anymore
[Music]
Jimmy Fallon auditions for The Voice and
shocks the coaches
[Applause]
the whole thing makes no sense The
Tonight Show host tries his hand at
getting a four-chair turn during a blind
audition prank his song of choice
Michael McDonald I keep forgetting every
time you're near
[Music]
yeah and Jimmy Well he kind of nailed it
it didn't take long for coaches Kelly
Clarkson Niall Horan and Chance the
Rapper to turn around
[Music]
it's an amazing experience but Mr Blake
Shelton didn't budge so Jimmy gets his
four chair turn himself
[Music]
[Applause]
I was like I know what's going on no way
I'm hitting my butt yeah you know
exactly a crush it crashed it I knew it
was you straight away he did he knew I
was like I thought you were Michael
McDonald's I turned first you're on my
team yeah yeah I'm on Kelly's team I'm
on Kelly's team right there thank you
for turning around Jimmy's no stranger
to singing shows he of course has his
own that's my jam which just kicked off
season two
[Applause]
[Music]
it's fun but it's a lot of crazy stuff
this season is nuts get ready it's a
it's a great season we have Chloe and
Hallie or do some they do a medley this
year that might be up there with that
Ariana and um it's it's the one yeah I
don't want to spoil it but it's going to
be it's gonna be big that was great Kiki
Palmer just came and destroyed she is so
talented lots of talented stars but
Jimmy does have his eyes on one dream
guest his pal Taylor Swift I'm full
unswifted really I love Taylor Swift
yeah will you sing with Taylor
whatever song you want to sing Taylor I
will sing with you any day of the week
anytime we can oh I love her yeah I'm
gonna Swift you all the way
[Music]